Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
Today I'd like to talk about one of the most incredible things our civilization
is capable of doing and that is the process of reengineering an entire planet or
moon to be suitable for earth life and subsequently to call night as those
worlds a process known commonly as terraforming.
Tara is Latin for earth,
so obviously it means to make like earth.
It sounds like science fiction,
but it may be coming to a planet near you much sooner than you think.
Hypothetically,
we could begin reengineering our best candidates today if we wanted to,
but how and where and why,
what we're going to cover all of that.
So let's get to it.
So what needs have to be fulfilled for us to be able to live on another world
indefinitely and independently?
Scientists have talked about colonizing basically every planet and major moon in
the solar system.
We could maybe build cities and gas giants,
atmospheres or bases on large asteroids,
but we're talking about terraforming here.
So we'll need something a bit more down to earth.
Rocky worlds liked for inner planets.
Mercury,
Venus,
Earth and Mars are as moon Jupiter's moons also called the Jovian moons and
Saturn's moon.
Titan can therefore start off as our main candidates.
These are mostly excellent worlds to consider building cities on however to
recreate earth.
Another important feature is obviously the ability to retain an earth like
atmosphere and temperatures.
We needed an atmospheric density of about one bar and one which keeps
temperatures at an ideal range constantly around every star.
There is a range in which a planet which could theoretically sustained surface
life as we know it would have to exist called the habitable zone.
The zone is based on the area around the star.
Wearing water can exist on the surface of a hypothetical earthlight world.
Scientists use it all the time when looking at exoplanets to determine potential
habitability,
our son's habitable zone begins around Venus and ends around Mars.
This alone excludes the Jovian moons,
Mercury and tightened,
and even if somehow the temperature issues were fixed,
these other worlds have other problems which would prevent terraforming.
Still the only be discussed briefly later on seeing as how Maurice has moons are
in reality just captured asteroids.
This leaves Venus,
the Moon and Mars.
Next we need a suitable level of gravity.
Gravity is necessary for a number of reasons.
A world first of all has to maintain an atmosphere you the gravity is too low,
the atmosphere will be lost the space over time.
Secondly,
as astronauts have found out the hard way,
spending too much time and low gravity is bad for the health.
In fact,
over the course of years in low g as it's called,
it will lead to a pleather of health problems and eventually death.
Venus is gravity at 90% that diverse is probably not an all an issue.
The Moon,
however,
at 16% could be a serious strain on health long term and could probably not hold
an atmosphere long enough so the moon is out.
It's gravity is simply too low.
Whether the 38% earth gravity that Maurice has a sufficient remains uncertain.
Mara's has in the past held a thick enough atmosphere for surface water to be
held in a long term and it may be just high enough to avoid health problems or
at least for those problems to be overcome somehow transitioning from low
gravity Mars earth would be difficult for potential future vacationers coming
back to the home world,
but we will of course include Mars in our terraforming discussion because
despite the fact that even though the gravity issue is uncertain,
Mars is too many people.
The best candidate of all the candidates for terraforming in the solar system.
This leaves Mars and Venus as a prime candidates for terror forming and our
solar system,
they're both large rocky worlds with potentially suitable gravity and distance
from the sun.
They're not unrealistically far either a trip to Venus or Mars other closest to
earth is under six months and that could be improved on as technology advances.
Crucially,
they both have water,
Mars much more so than Venus,
but in the right conditions,
oceans would form on both worlds.
Sometimes even they already remind us of home,
but the key here in my opinion is that this is not all theoretical travel back 4
billion years is so to the infancy of the solar system and you might not be able
to easily tell which planet is earth at first.
That's because of this time Mars and Venus both had large bodies of liquid water
on the surface over time.
However,
Mars and Venus lust this habitability,
whether they developed life is of course unknown,
whether they retain that life is also a known but only earth developed into a
stable world,
flourishing with a diversity of life.
The challenge of terraforming therefore is to return Mars and Venus if those
conditions aren't officially and then gradually introduce earth life.
Our microorganisms are plants,
our animals and of course ourselves,
and of course it should be able to be kept that way indefinitely.
Now,
let's run through some basic issues here.
Mars and Venus coincidentally have many opposite problems,
so we're going to have to develop different game plans for each world.
Venus is far too hot.
The surface temperature averages at 462 degrees Celsius or 860 degrees
Fahrenheit.
That atmosphere contains a number of toxic chemicals and it's heavy to the
atmospheric pressure on Venus is 90 times out of earth,
which would essentially crush you.
Other problems which we'll discuss exists such as another feature.
The fact that Venus rotates incredibly slowly.
That is to say that one day on Venus last 188 earth days.
This may just be a major inconvenience though,
not necessarily a make or break problem.
On the other hand,
the surface temperature of Mars is about negative 81 degrees Fahrenheit or a
negative 62 degrees Celsius.
The atmosphere is 100 times less dense than the earth,
so even if it were warm enough for liquid water to exist on the surface,
there wouldn't be enough pressure for it to remain in that form.
Coincidentally,
Mars is day is only slightly longer than the,
it's just above 24 hours,
but the year is twice as long.
However,
of course that's not necessarily an impediment to life or anything important to
note though both planets also lack of suitable magnetic field to protect from
solar radiation that were shielded from here on earth.
This radiation could cause serious problems for life even if other conditions
are working out.
So naturally we'll have to figure something out for that.
And for whatever reason,
the magnetic field issue is an issue which is not very commonly discussed in
terraforming conversations,
itching.
It's an issue which is sometimes ignored and they understand that it's the bane
of a tear formers existence because it's an issue that is not easily solved.
However,
there are solutions to it and we will be discussing those in this video.
So even if you're already kind of familiar with terra forming,
you may be introduced to some new things through this video.
Back to Mars.
Perhaps you've noticed as many scientists have,
it sounds like Mars needs a dose of global warming,
something we already know how to do.
The first step to terraforming Mars is to get the surface warmer and the
atmosphere thicker.
We know how to do that.
We're doing it here on earth and it is a Middle East creating problems,
but on Mars the same process will be beneficial to life.
The question is how importing fossil fuels from earth is extremely impractical,
especially from the viewpoint of modern technological limits and even if done
intentionally would probably take too long.
We might have to resort to more extreme local methods for raising the
temperature.
If we can raise Mars,
his temperature was sufficient.
Greenhouse gas emissions that will cause more gas he released,
which will then aid and raising the temperature as well to an even greater
degree.
One theory made popular by though not originating with Elon Musk is to drop
nuclear bombs on the planet's polls,
which hold large amounts of frozen carbon dioxide or well known greenhouse gas
in this forum known more commonly here on Earth as dry ice.
This obviously creates the problem of nuclear fallout,
but an even bigger issue is how to ship an entire arsenal of nuclear weapons
throughout the solar system.
Asteroids redirected to hit Mars as Paul's would have a similar effect.
There are more a gentle suggestions to raising the temperature is such as mask
in the surface and a darker substance in a natural soil,
specifically the Poles so that less sunlight is reflected back into space.
Thankfully,
Mars's moons are some of the darkest objects in the solar system,
so with source for such as substance would be nearby.
Another suggestion is to place giant mirrors in orbit around Mars to redirect
more sunlight to hit the planet,
thus causing the temperature to rise.
Personally,
I don't see how combining several tactics is a bad idea,
especially if we're looking to get the atmosphere suitable within 100 to 200
years.
Regardless of how we approach it,
I think it would be wise to introduce life onto the surface as soon as possible.
Cyanobacteria are a prime candidate for the first.
Some Mars.
There are rugged life form called an extreme of file,
meaning they thrive and conditions which most life would find in hospital.
Theoretically speaking,
this could include Mars.
CYANOBACTERIA would be instrumental in preparing the surface her other life
forms such as plants by lacing the soil with nitrogen and other elements and
converting the carbon dioxide in the atmosphere and to breathable oxygen like
they do here on earth as well as creating an ozone layer.
Cyanobacteria is also edible and can be used as fuel and environment with no
fossil fuels,
no wind power and less powerful solar power sign of bacteria have a good work
reference as well.
They've already accomplished much of this on earth and are responsible in part
for turning the planet into the habit of a world it is today.
However,
before we start introducing earth life to Mars,
we need to be certain of one thing that there is not already life on the plant.
The same issue must be addressed for Venus as well,
but it's much more likely that Mars how has slack than Venus?
Although I've talked about how both are possible and pass videos.
If either world host's living organisms introducing our life to their planet,
imprudently could seriously damaged their ecosystem,
maybe irreparably almost certainly if life were found on Mars,
it would not be more advanced in bacteria and though perhaps biologically
independent from earth life,
but probably function very similarly.
This brings us to a philosophical debate within the scientific community and
what do we do if that's the case,
how does life being found on another planet?
Change our plans for colonization?
As I said,
we could damage the Martian ecosystem by terraforming the plant.
Some argue that avoiding terraforming and colonization for this reason is
essentially sacrificing the future of humanity for an organism.
No more complex than bacteria.
Other people see this as interfering with the biology of another world.
For our own selfish purposes considering that native marsh in life would
probably do much better in a terraform and climate because as I said,
it would be in all likelihood similar to earth life.
Many people suggest coexistence,
but again,
even among the most ardent terra formers and astrobiologists,
there is a disagreement and I'd like to take this opportunity to note
specifically for those who claim that philosophy is dead,
that despite all this incredible technology and science,
none of it can be put to use before our philosophical questions are answered as
well.
I will mention though,
in case you're wondering,
as I discussed in one of my earlier videos,
Martian life is almost certainly not going to cause diseases in humans,
infectious bacteria and viruses and all of that have to evolve specifically to
penetrate and function in another organism.
Obviously there has never been in 4.5 billion years such an opportunity on Mars,
so you are not going to be contaminated.
It's more likely that our organisms are going to disrupt the natural habitat of
any native organisms there over the course of decades.
Assuming we employ combined strategies to terraforming the planet.
Mars is that Mrs t were thick and the planet would begin to warm up.
It would snow on Mars,
it would rain,
rivers would flow ocean to begin to form,
and the planet may eventually looked something like this.
The next step would be to introduce more complex plant life to surface to really
begin converting the carbon dioxide into oxygen.
I've imagined plain like machines flying over certain areas of Mars just
dropping thousands and thousands of plants.
Seeds.
These plants may in all likelihood be genetically engineered to be darker,
to attract more sunlight or to produce more oxygen within another centuries.
So the Martian surface can be very green,
perhaps with heaviest systems from artificial methods.
Columnist on the planet could leave their giant artificial dome cities and take
off their helmets outside and breathe the Martian air for the first time.
Once that is possible,
a day on Mars would look a lot like a day on earth.
You can try to imagine walking outside on a warm or night on Mars from your
futuristic house among the first few generations of forests and green hills and
such and looking up at the sky.
The constellations would all appear as they do here on earth,
despite the fact that they'd move slightly differently.
And by that I mean the North Star for example,
wouldn't be the north star because Mars has tilt is slightly different instead
of one giant moon.
However,
as we're used to here on earth,
Martians would see two asteroids.
The more visible being Phobos and Deimos,
which would appear smaller than Phobos as a large point of light in the sky.
Importantly in that sky as well would be a significant Pale bluish star.
Not really a star,
but a planet earth,
earth from the sky of Mars,
Venus,
or anywhere else in the solar system for that matter,
closer to than Saturn would serve as a reminder to the colonists of those worlds
that we once believe that.in the sky to be all that there was.
But now we've grown and advanced metaphorically and physically and come to
venture too.
And inhabit worlds,
which we also won saw only as dots in the sky.
Earth will always be our home,
but the human perspective of what constitutes the definition of the world will
have grown incredibly.
We talked today about our global society,
how our civilization works as one planet,
a perspective which is radically different from the one people had 500 or so
years ago,
but perhaps a few hundred years in the future we may regard society and more
than that civilization and more than that humanity as something which exists
around the sun on many worlds,
much more intricate than what we think of today.
I don't mean to get too off track with all this.
I just think it's interesting to consider looking up at the sky and considering
that civilization and people exist up there as well anyway,
even though Maurice would technically be habitable at this point,
other issues would nationally still remain.
It would still probably take at least another century for the tear and marsh and
ecosystem to fully develop.
And we haven't even discussed the generation of a magnetosphere yet,
which is crucial even for the most basic level of life.
But how long would it take for Mars to look blue and green like earth?
It's hard to say.
Even major scientists don't have a single estimate because there are several
different approaches to terra forming and I don't want to calculate how much
faster future technology will make terror for me because that technology doesn't
even exist yet.
But I also don't think it makes much sense to assume that we won't develop new
technology within the next few centuries.
For example,
I remember watching something one time a long time ago with someone talking
about how we can just move humanity to Mars and the sun becomes hotter and you
know,
a few billion years.
And I just thought it was shortsighted to assume that we'll still be living on a
single planet for the next few billion years.
But anyway,
I'd say that with full effort given we could have something like ocean starting
to form within 100 years and maybe have an ability within 200 more years.
Again,
that's the best estimate.
It might take longer or future technology could make it shorter.
No one honestly knows for sure,
but if we started today,
I personally would put the deadline on the year 2,317 let's move on to Venus.
As mentioned,
Venus has the opposite problem.
The key here at first is to try to cool the planet down and reduce the pressure
of the crushing atmosphere.
A number of methods have been proposed to do this.
Where on Mars we suggest a giant orbiting mirrors to reflect sunlight on the
surface.
On Venus,
we could use giant orbiting shades to block that sunlight and cool the planet
off that way.
Balloons designed to reflect sunlight place in the atmosphere could also help to
this end.
Now on Mars,
I briefly mentioned domed artificial cities.
Basically colonists could live on the surface and giant domes like this,
which would maintain earth conditions within,
but on Venus it would be much harder to do that because of the external forces
and alternative made popular by Jeffrey Landis is to build the short term
terraforming colonies or transition colonies,
I guess you could call them in the atmosphere.
The surface of Venus is very inhospitable,
but there's an area higher in the atmosphere where the temperature is actually
kind of Nice and the atmospheric pressure isn't too bad.
It's still toxic and not breathable.
He wouldn't want to just wander outside in it,
but you could probably be fine in just the space.
Land is suggestion is to build giant cities in the atmosphere which are hoisted
by balloons.
It seems a little far fetched,
but it actually wouldn't be that difficult to construct because as land is
pointed out,
the gases that we're used to on earth,
oxygen and nitrogen would float and Venus's atmosphere anyway.
In his words.
If you take the room that you're sitting in right now,
seal it off and make the walls a little bit lighter,
it would actually float in the minutia and atmosphere.
From there,
we could use genetically engineered plants to convert the carbon dioxide into
oxygen or probably machines which served the same purpose more efficiently.
We would still have to reduce atmospheric density to live on the surface as
well.
Some suggestions to meeting that goal and could bombarding Venus with hydrogen.
This would cause something called the Bosch reaction,
which would eventually turn carbon dioxide into graphite,
which is what pencil lead really is,
and water which has an added benefit because Venus needs water.
It has some,
but a lot of its water was lost his space over time because of solar winds and
the lack of that magnetic field.
Again,
something along the lines of the Bosch reaction would reduce both the pressure
and the temperature of the atmosphere.
It's been suggested that we could also directly or moving this his atmosphere by
perhaps blasting it off with huge asteroid impacts or collecting it with
machines and shooting and off the planet.
Regarding the astroid concept.
The issue with that is mostly that Venus would likely recollect it's atmosphere
again over time because it wouldn't be injected very far off into space.
Furthermore,
it would take a large number of such impacts to make a significant dent in
Venus's atmosphere.
Secondly,
it's been suggested that we could not only,
as I said,
artificially or move the atmosphere,
but that we could transport Venus's CO2 to terraform Mars at the same time.
That would take a huge amount of time and resources.
However,
and I personally tend to regard ideas like shipping CO2 from Venus to Mars or
water from Europa to Venus or anything that requires interplanetary exchange on
a massive scale as out of our current or near technological limitations.
It's possible certainly,
but I think the best methods are the ones that are currently feasible,
not best in a sense that it's the most effective,
but the most reliable.
There was also the issue I mentioned of the slow rotation,
as I said,
sunrise to sunset would last about 116 earth days and that is a bit of a
nuisance at first.
We could overcome this artificially.
Maybe cities could employ giant shades to create an artificial night or
something of that nature,
but we could also speed the rotation up.
This would be kind of dangerous so it couldn't be sloppy,
but we could theoretically give Venus huge numbers of ashred moons which orbit
the planet quickly over time and with more advanced methods,
this could create a faster spin.
Another fun fact is that Venus rotates backwards compared to the earth.
The Sun would rise in the west and set in the east,
but that wouldn't be obviously an issue regarding habitability.
However,
we may want to hold off on our officially making the planet spin faster and I
suppose we'd have to anyway because the technology required to do so is beyond
our level.
We'd want to hold off because a slowly rotating plant would actually be
beneficial to the terraforming effort with Venus.
Slowly,
it would cause large cloud formations on a sunny side of the planet to forum
which would reflect sunlight and keep the planet cool.
It has been hypothesized that the daytime would be rainy,
warm,
and cloudy,
but the nighttime side would actually be pretty cold.
Living on Venus would be a little bit like living in Alaska or Siberia,
especially with the constant presence or lack of the sun.
At that point,
we would repeat the same process that we use on Mars of introducing life
graduates to the planet and creating a tear and venuzio and ecosystem.
Because Venus is such as smooth planet,
its surface would be about 80% covered with water,
despite the fact that it would only take about 10% the water of earth to do that
accordingly.
As you can see here,
artists,
depictions of Venus often show a large amount of islands and a lot of sea.
I'm sure you're going imagine living on Venus in a city near the coast,
going outside on a typical,
the Newseum day,
rainy and warm,
no moons would exist in Venus is sky and that night the stars would appear
frozen,
turning only very slowly as a night with last for over a hundred days from
earth.
The Morningstar as Venus has called being the third brightest object in our sky
would become less bright and would turn blue.
And what about the magnetic fields of both planets?
Well,
those are currently,
as I said,
one of the hardest parts of terraforming to address because it's not something
which we have,
which we have experienced fooling around with here on earth.
It's something that we've been fortunate enough to naturally have and magnetic
fields serves a purpose of reflecting cosmic radiation which can harm organisms
and strip away the atmospheres of the terraform to worlds and things of that
nature.
Earth's magnetic field is created from molten metal and the core of the planet's
spinning and churning inside it in Venus and Mars.
These cores of cooled down far too much,
obviously a direct approach.
This problem is to get the core hot again here on earth.
The gravitational forces of our moon tug at our planet's insights,
keeping them moving around.
Theoretically,
the introduction of large amounts of astroid moons like I mentioned earlier with
getting Venus has been faster,
could also get the cores of Mars and Venus more active as well.
We could also attempt to create nuclear explosions in the mantle or hit the
planets with very large asteroids.
Something that would obviously have to be done very early in the terraforming
phases.
This approach will take time,
however,
in technology beyond a current limits.
So in the meantime,
the construction of some form of artificial magnetic field would probably have
to be employed as well.
So in a nutshell,
that's how we could terraform Mars and Venus on Mars introducing the frozen
carbon dioxide and Marta's poles into the atmosphere and converting that
atmosphere into a breathable one using micro organisms and other methods and
then generating a magnetic field is essentially all it would take to terraform
Mars for Venus,
reducing the atmospheric density and pressure somehow by converting and are
moving the carbon dioxide in the atmosphere.
Probably through the boss' reaction as it would give Venus much needed water
generating the magnetic field as well and possibly one day getting the planet
has been faster is essentially what it would take to terraform.
Venus.
Obviously it's not entirely so simple.
There are many other concerns and there will likely be other problems that we
aren't even aware of yet.
Worst of all,
we could even somehow screw up and prolong the terraforming process or even make
a planet even more inhospitable.
However,
those steps are the basic steps to getting the job done.
Assuredly,
this is all easier said than done.
However,
it's not so complex that we can't begin the process today with our current level
of technology.
Terraforming has always been one of my personal favorite concepts and all of
astronomy and science.
It's up there with extra terrestrial life and things like that.
And when I first looked into this when I was a younger kid,
I like many other people,
was not satisfied with just one or two planets alone.
Probably about 70% of the terraform in conversation is about Mars.
Terra forming Venus is a little bit less of a popular subjects,
but avid terror formers know that Venus is the real deal too.
But what many people,
including my younger self wants to know is why stopped there?
What about mercury?
The Jovian Moons Titan,
our moon,
Luna,
or even other worlds?
I mentioned earlier at the beginning of this video that they were unfeasible and
I'll take some time to explain terraforming on those worlds.
Now some people ask first of all about terraforming the sun.
I'd say that for very obvious reasons,
terraforming a star is out of the question and makes no sense and would
furthermore probably cause extinction on all the other worlds in a slow system
which could be tear formed along with the earth.
Moving on,
gas giants,
could we tear formed Jupiter,
Saturn,
Uranus or Neptune?
The question makes more sense,
but it's still unrealistic I guess.
Giant has no solid surface to terraform.
Just a rocky,
highly pressurized core surrounded by extremely thick clouds of hydrogen and
helium.
We could strip away the atmospheres of the gas giants had tried to work with the
rocky core for that process is again extremely unrealistic.
You're talking about removing like 90% of the mass of a planet 100 times or more
of the size of the earth.
Not to mention gas giants aren't even in the habitable zone.
One could argue some exotic method to terraforming something like Jupiter and it
would be a worthwhile thought experiment.
However,
here's the bottom line.
If it would be easier and more beneficial to create artificial self sufficient
space,
station,
city type things in orbit around the sun or a gas giant or wherever,
then it would be more rational to pursue something like that.
Then something as extreme and impractical as terraforming and entire gas giant
gas giants are out.
I would honestly rather suggest just constructing an entirely new planet and
terraforming Jupiter.
What about mercury?
Mercury is interesting and that it has a gravity as strong as Mars,
but even with no atmosphere,
it is far too hot and atmosphere would only make this worse.
Some bizarre method of cooling the planet and shielding it from the sun,
again,
would be more costly than building an artificial space station to the same
effect mercury is out.
However,
some people have suggested what is called Para terraforming parrots.
Terra forming is essentially the halfway between building artificial dumps it
he's like we mentioned earlier with Mars and terraforming.
It's essentially where giant structures which expand across an entire planet,
or at least large portions of the planet are constructed to create an artificial
climate to us today.
This sounds like in circling something like mercury in a giant Shell made of
durable,
advanced technology or something of that nature,
but regardless of how practical this is,
constructing such a thing on a scale of an entire planet is something well
outside our current technological capabilities.
What about the moon?
Also known as Luna?
Luna is,
as I said,
too small to hold an atmosphere for very long.
At the beginning of the video,
I counted the moon out.
It's in the habitable zone.
Obviously it's a rocky world,
but it's just too small,
and our efforts would be better spent working with Mars and Venus.
It has been suggested,
however,
that there is a way to terraform it on a,
on a cosmic scale.
Luna is not large enough to maintain an atmosphere of its own.
However,
it could in theory,
hold an earth like atmosphere for a span of a few thousand years,
which is a pretty decent amount of time from the human perspective.
Future colonists would simply have to regulate the atmosphere and replenish it
whenever necessary.
The process of terra forming the moon involved with bombarding it with comments
containing a large amount of water.
Scientists have calculated that about 100 comments is size of how he's comment
will be sufficient to deliver necessary amounts of waters of the moon,
build up accrued atmosphere from the impacts and even get the moon spinning as
one day on the moon lasts about 28 earth days,
which is problematic.
Obviously this would have to be precise.
We would definitely not want to be throwing comments around and screwing with an
object so close to home.
From there,
when the surface settles from having been bombarded heavily,
more precise conversion of the atmosphere will begin life both natural and
probably more so genetically engineered would be introduced to Luna and in
theory we could turn the gray object we see in the sky into a blue and green
one.
This doesn't solve the problem of the very low gravity,
however,
which wouldn't be an issue for short term visitors but would be for permanent
residence.
The combination of an earth lag atmosphere in such low gravity,
however,
would lead to some very interesting possibilities.
A human being could essentially strap on a pair of fake wings and actually fly
through the hypothetical atmosphere of our moon.
This is already possible on Saturn's moon titan.
If we aren't able to get the moon spinning.
Daytime and nighttime maybe very complicated and uncomfortable,
and the moon as well has no magnetic field to defend against solar.
Some have suggested that we simply resolve this by living in the moon's caves.
However,
why bother with the rest of the moon?
If we're restricted to the caves,
we'd have to generate an artificial magnetic field.
I'm not saying terraforming Luna is impossible.
There are a number of good theories surrounding terra forming it,
but for now we should leave it as a maybe just because it's more complex and
Martha Venus and somewhat out of our technological capabilities.
What about Jupiter's unknowns,
Europa,
Ganymede,
Calista and io?
Well,
first things first,
we have the same issue of very low gravity,
again,
lower than the moon.
In fact.
Secondly,
these moons are outside the huddle zone,
so we would have to create a greenhouse effect which can cope with much lower
sunlight.
Now,
Europa specifically here is in my opinion,
the best candidate to find alien life and the source system.
It may even have multicellular organisms swimming in the ocean which exists
under it thick shell of ice.
If life that complex exists there,
terraform in the world could disrupted.
Secondly,
Europa has a lot of water,
a lot more water than even earth actually in terra forming.
It would essentially create a giant ocean world with no surface to colonize.
This obviously would make terraforming and colonization,
incredibly implausible,
and this is a case for Ganymede and Calista as well.
Io is simply extremely volatile as our each of the moons around Jupiter,
because of their orbit around the giant planet,
the Jovian moons are out because they are impractical.
We furthermore see a very similar problem with Saturn's moon titan.
Even if we dealt with how far titan is from the sun,
we'd still end up with an ocean world and conditions that are not at all ideal
for terraforming and longterm human habitability.
And the farther away from the sun you get from there,
the more impractical terraform and becomes,
the more impractical the terraforming becomes.
The more exotic you have to get,
the more exotic you have to get,
the more you have to invest into it and the more you have to invest into it,
the greater the incentive is to just build artificial space stations or dome
cities or even pair terra formed type structures.
Mars and Venus having been the stars of this video are obviously our best
candidates.
The moon is a possibility.
Mercury,
the gas giants and their moons and the rest of the solar system are not very
feasible.
As humanity would move out to colonize the entire solar system,
founding bases,
towns and cities from mercury to Pluto.
We would have Mars and Venus as a symbols of our optimism and determination and
our expansion into the rest of the galaxy where we may find other earth like
world's possibly extra terrestrial life forms.
But my guess would be that we will find many more worlds in need of some terra
forming than there are already habitable.
What we would be doing in our solar system would be the first steps to creating
scores of re-engineered world's throughout the galaxy on which we may spread the
great variety of earth life and allow it to diversify and limitless new ways.
We've discussed when we have discussed how but who would do this and why anyone
paying attention to the modern space programs throughout the world knows is that
there isn't much to pay attention to.
Governments are simply not interested in space.
However,
private individuals and organizations are smart enough to be,
it's an uphill battle to convince the public to fund a space program.
Average people tend to look down on things that don't put bread on the table or
a gas in the car as the expression goes,
so I personally do not put huge faith and world governments or popular demand to
begin a tariff on processes.
In fact,
in my opinion,
the biggest problem in terraforming would be securing long term support Merith.
I think therefore the terraforming of Mars and Venus would be left in the hands
of the people who plant lives there.
The handful of visionaries who are capable of seeing where our civilization has
headed,
that the average person is not capable of.
Why should we do it?
Well,
there are a number of benefits to having not one but three inhabited worlds in
our solar system.
The most important is that we are better securing the future of earth,
life,
and humanity for billions of years.
If something catastrophic were to happen to one of the three planets to others
would continue on.
Furthermore,
even if humans were to disappear,
life on Venus and Mars could take its own path and evolve in new ways.
In our absence,
of course,
to increase our odds of survival for much longer,
we'd have to leave the solar system altogether.
There would of course be large amounts of people who objected,
terraforming,
which is why I don't think we should even bother leaving the decision in the
hands of the populous at home.
We should leave it in the hands of the pioneers in themselves.
This may mean that it won't be similar to having something like American,
British,
Chinese,
French,
etc. Colonies on Mars or Venus,
but we may see that the settlers just found their own societies right off the
bat.
They would likely mix earth culture and ways of life as they adapt and create a
new culture based on the planet on which they live.
I think it would be interesting to see the kinds of ways people adapt socially,
culturally,
and politically to new planets.
Would they speak earth languages or create new languages to unify those
societies?
How would they adapt new calendars?
I'm Marcia near last twice as long as there's so would you wait twice as long
for a birthday or have it twice a year?
Could war break out between societies on different planets?
Would there be much reason for interplanetary war?
How would life in general respond to being on new planets?
How will life evolve and new conditions such as a long days and nights on Venus,
much closer to the sun or the much lower gravity on Mars?
These are all very interesting questions that we should spend time thinking
about and often may criticism of venturing off into space is that we have an
obligation to fix our world at home before we go off into the cosmos.
However,
though mistakes were made in our history of exploring earth,
exploration has always made us a better people.
And I would say that the societies which go out and explore and settle new
worlds develop much more than those which sit around and focus on domestic
problems that may exist.
And definitely for more videos like this and videos on many other subjects,
be sure to check out fire of learning and subscribe.
And of course you can also find us on Facebook and Instagram.
Thank you for watching.